one comic is better than the other
people think it's them
we're smoking and joking and having a
[Music]
two
blast
two cigars
that's the vitamin water bobby i got it
we're really coming up in the world
we're coming up welcome to two what is
it two comics two comics two cigars two
cigars two
two always and forever today is my treat
we're here at the uh green room of 20
glc live at 20 monroe said can i smoke
and they said do whatever the [ __ ] you
want oh
so that's for another time oh really for
another we'll do that like we'll do oh
don't tell him what it is but we'll do
that i mean dude yeah that'll be a fun
one oh it's a car
really good cigar we're not talking
about that bobby we're not talking about
it but you showed me it right now
do you have you ever heard of this
talking about the perez carrigero
oh my stomach the pledge well that was
there before we just cut that out okay
cut that out only ari
all right
have you heard of this one yeah so the
reason i bring you this is because i
just got them yeah i was in um do you
know anything about the cigar i do not
money shot it was not it was named
cigar fashion hour 2020 cigar of the
year 2020
highest rated ever at 98 percent are you
[ __ ] me read this well you can't i
can't i have it right all those things i
have it
cigar of the year 2020 dude highest
rated cigar ever yeah wow these are
about 12 i got him in lakeland florida
and i smoked him with steve simone for
his birthday in his new house right uh
in lakeland perez carrillo take a look
at that there's your money shot oh we'll
put it in there put the money shot [ __ ]
in there toast it dude i feel i got a
chopper
i do
it's in my bag where's your bag
it's right there okay
it's right on the thing over there
this yes this is it no bring that whole
thing over here okay
it's in here somewhere
so the road so far has been [ __ ] good
uh we were trying to smoke a cigar
yesterday it wasn't [ __ ] happening
all right let's get the [ __ ] cover
where's the thing
okay
yeah
i gotta get comfortable
okay did we start this too early huh did
we start this too early i mean you
jumped in i mean yeah we don't have much
time we don't we gotta go but we got to
edit around there's a couple times when
my stomach was out stomach's out dude
they're natural this is a natural
podcast
people need to see these foibles
oh man but it's not good
i mean those chairs they'll see you lose
weight over the course of this i am
going to lose weight by the summer
listen i we went to a we'll talk about
why i feel very swollen here let me see
your cigar ihop this is brought to you
by ihop you're gonna chop for me
yes i do
chop off make a little eye yeah you want
to make a little eye
and then snap it yeah and there you go
so the guy told me he was like these are
amazing if you're looking to get
anything get these and i was thinking
about it it's this like a cigar shop in
[ __ ] i don't remember the name of it
but i got two other cigars there too and
i thought of you and i was like not only
am i getting two for me and steve simone
on his birthday i'm like i went oh
that's we went back i'm like i've got to
get two of these so i can smoke one with
bobby now the correct way to a lighter
cigar we'll do this really quickly okay
toast it do not let the blue flame do
not let the blue flame
just let the heat hit the top of the
cigar
and you want to get it rosy rosie
rosie rosie
blow on it see that
see that
you want okay
the the flame is not touching
see now i can see where it needs a
little toast
now
see that
now this is
the first taste of the cigar is not the
match not the sulfur not the lighter
it's the what they wanted you when they
rolled the cigar so there's no right way
to light a cigar
is this it
or just light the cigar that is true
both are options both
that's the right way i love when people
tell you that it's like don't oh do you
don't you never put salt in a chef's
food like why is there salt on the table
then
why is there ketchup here at this
restaurant if they don't want you to
have that well good restaurants don't
have salt or pepper on the table yeah
and if you ask for it they they are your
wife and it ruined thanksgiving
i didn't
that's not what ruined thanksgiving
yes
that way of you lighting it the way you
like you can let it just let it in your
mouth
that way regular way light it turn it
suck it get all the fumes inside there
here's what i do
is i have a match
i have a match yeah
my ass in your face oh
this joke's still on the show this isn't
all about serious stuff no no no no
you're getting the sulphur in the
[ __ ] cigar
that is terrible etiquette
i mean cigar people right now are
watching this going this guy's an
[ __ ] that is t what are you doing the
stuff is already burned off it burns off
immediately no it does not fluff our
first thing that's what makes it fly it
does not burn off first thing you got to
let it burn off get into the wood
you're lit you're done
ladies and gentlemen that's how you
light a cigar
not just any car
cigars aficionados 20 20 cigar of the
year okay what's your first taste
let me tell you another story of this
yeah uh we went back we had a great
weekend in tampa meeting steve yeah
saved his house hung out with his
parents i was like let's celebrate a
great weekend get a cigar and he goes
i'm buying and i was like [ __ ]
and he goes do you want to get one of
those that we just smoked because it was
so good and i said no and i asked you
for a suggestion
they had one of those i got too long
what would you suggest you remember
i don't
all right either
it was too long
and i got sick by the end of it and it
was like 35
and this was 12 and i told him was it a
davidoff nope
was it a tattoo
i believe it might have been was it a
gran kahane nope what else
a j21 for sure not
a judge from my father no no no
really oh was it a perdomo perdomo
you was a pretty stick on the [ __ ]
extra long one because i asked for the
most expensive one like a [ __ ] idiot
and half of that is because of the
length i should have gotten a shorter
one toro
robusto robusto
i think robusto's six inches i don't
know what those words mean okay when you
get a cigar for me
this is perfect for the time limit we
have an hour yeah 45 minutes okay yeah
okay
when you're smoking a scottish sit down
six inches
anywhere from 50
50 ring gauge which is the roundness of
it or up what are you looking for window
to open [ __ ] that that's not gonna
happen rock and roll man
it is cool to see who's liking uh
go ahead finish with your side but
anyways there you go so yeah you
shouldn't you shouldn't have so what do
i ask for to say if i want a shorter one
not a stubby like a nothing i want a six
inch cigar this is a small cigar this is
a five inch maybe
five inches and it's a solid
[ __ ] length for me yeah
we're gonna put all the information on
this cigar i mean dude this cigar right
out of the gate
is [ __ ] nice nice right it's it's got
some umph
it's not too light
it's on the back of my tongue right now
mm-hmm i can taste it it's got a little
little bite a little spice yeah a little
bite
how cool is it to see which other bands
have played here
yeah me and jay went over like just say
like if we're at a festival not who you
buy tickets for right if you're at a
music festival yeah and somebody's like
whoever's on that wall is like they're
playing across the field so tell me what
you want to go you'll be like yeah sure
i'll check them out which bands are
those would you play marilyn manson for
sure right yeah it's fun to see how many
well i think i have like 15 that have
been here it's funny to me my son is
like this too yeah you and jay are music
people yeah you love going to concerts
you love
you know songs i don't know
i love music i don't know songs jay no
songs
he's savant yeah he knows the drummers
he knows the names i don't even know the
names of the songs of my favorite band
if i love arcade fire like what about
this i'm like which one is that i i
don't i just don't i don't know i don't
know anything yeah i know kelly clarkson
that's it if since you've been gone
is that her yeah
i can breathe for the first time i'm so
moving on yeah yeah she's a game show
host because of you
i get what i want
talk show
talk show host
that was your walk on music for your
wedding i love her i love her um
yeah i don't know that but i do i look
at you know you don't give a [ __ ] about
the bands no can i not that i don't give
a [ __ ] that's totally the wrong thing i
do but i don't know like i remember me
and you did a festival we did a jazz
festival which one
blues fest blues festival ottawa
and that's when we first really hung out
me and you
i remember trading [ __ ] podcast
secrets in your hotel room you were
leaving i was coming you were there with
brewer or something right i was there
and then you came in
you did a night with me
i taught you about the zoom
about bringing zoom i think about that
what i remember telling you about that
no i told you
dude you think you told me about a zoom
yeah you didn't know about zoom marc
maron told me marc maron told me and i'm
the one who please go listen to the
podcast wait what is it you know what
dude negative mind is please
please go miss listen to that podcast
what that's lost in the ether already oh
i'll find him over 10 years ago no you
no
oh no what was blue fest jay's you went
with us at blutz fest the year after
blue is fast first time i talked to
bobby and we we hung out we actually
walked around we did [ __ ] together and
then i remember in the middle of my set
and i outf uh um what's the guys um
alfonso no rivera no fonzo rivera oh my
brain is fresh prince of bel-air no no
alonzo bowden thank you elijah bowden
was there for one night
me
you were there and then you left pretty
sure it was up front we were there and
left and then he came or did he was he
there and left and you came is that a
knock what does it matter okay rocker
roll
he was never there with me
alfonso okay so anyways in the middle of
the thing like 30 50 people would just
get up and leave and i was like what did
i say i was in the tent it was in the
tent no it was in a building
oh yeah
come in
come in
oh it's okay cool so did you want a
specific walk-up song oh yeah um yeah
um i'm about kelly clarkson
i love i love that one no um
no not breakaway it's all right
um like i said i don't know music um
nope james brown nope come on jay jimmy
world no come together by who
come on yellow
no [ __ ] john
who did the best version of it jimi
hendrix
yeah you ever hear that one
really yeah
no way that's a good song but i will be
listening for it
uh how are we doing how yeah who's going
to first of the show what are we doing
is it me and then you
and i you'll go first to him and then
follow the opposite okay all right so
yeah yeah oh yeah so we're doing it
first they'll god mike me on
they'll god make me on and then play the
music
yeah he goes first and he's bringing him
up then he's going to go back up and
then he's going to bring me up and then
all three are going back on and then we
say good night
all right man thank you guys i
appreciate it thank you brother
yeah there's a clock
so you don't know music is what you were
saying i love music i don't know music
like jay knows music oh you know but i
remember you were like dude let's go
let's go out there and watch the music
and it was you know who it was chris
connell
what a [ __ ] question and i remember
going out there like i'm you talking
about introverts today yeah and i'm an
introvert and i don't even know it until
today
i never thought i've never because i was
like no i'll just i'd rather just go and
sit somewhere or go get some food or go
back to the hotel or whatever and do a
podcast or what whatever and you're like
chris cornell's playing yeah cornell's
playing and we went out and we sat side
you got us tickets yeah yes that book
yeah experts and i was introverted that
night
and i we went out and watched chris
connell and it was how'd you feel dude
[ __ ] um he was so good he was so good
but also you can be introverted in a big
crowd it was just like you stand back
you stand farther away you don't go
right to the middle in the front row i
think that's what we did in the middle
front row well we got we got we got like
special tickets we're on the side
because we were in we were you know uh
artists artists so you know who told me
about that oh big j okay the third
member of our [ __ ] road group here
yes the third comic two cigars two
comics two cigars only all the time
there's no three comics if you send into
three comics if you threaten three
cigars it has to be the same two cigars
two cigars two comics smoking cigar
talking about this
yup show us a little bit about the cigar
and then go ahead
uh
we waited off camera we waited through a
rainstorm
to see the black keys out of a blues
fest because ari's like they're so good
live and i waited and we had a blast
nice i had a blast there keep waiting
for these stories to go and i told you
it sucked because they're comedians but
no you guys did have a good time oh look
man you took us too so jay told me that
was the year before and he goes let's
try to go up in the sound booth the
middle of that [ __ ] big where the
main stage is a giant it looks like
still straight up a [ __ ]
apartment in the sky and i was like we
can't go up there and jay's like no
we're artists and they go i'm like yeah
tactically we're artists but not really
and he's like no yeah really and i'm
like no he goes he's like look at our
passes it says artist i'm like yeah but
we're just comedians because they don't
there's no difference there
and then uh i've really abused it since
then
i've never i didn't know that either i
don't like big crowds though mushroom's
in perfect circle right there i remember
you guys were there that was bonnaroo
nope that was out in [ __ ] nashville
outside of nashville a perfect circle of
mushrooms mushrooms yeah
and
no no we took mushrooms and did uh two
comics
two comics
two cigars we watched uh
what you do you remember earth one that
fire oof that ruled do you remember
wow that guy one of the guys in the band
was easily 65 years old and he
he plays standing drums and jump kicks
the symbol for the cymbal hit i can do
that no it's up here bob he swings his
leg up i was off camera i was kidding
you know what i'm saying when i say it's
up here i'll do it up here i believe he
could do it if you put your hand up
there we can see it on camera him doing
it
but i believe in you bobby can i tell
you why
i have a fear of comics i mean not
comics of big shows like that
is i went to van halen van hagar yeah uh
5150 tour
uh general admission rochester red wings
stadium baseball stadium i got front row
i got so drunk and [ __ ] up ran to the
front and i got stuck
and i started getting smushed oh and i
got panicked
and i literally had a headache
no it's worse than that you go in
and you shut down and you almost start
to cry because you nobody cares
nobody they only care about and eddie
you know who doesn't care too [ __ ]
eddie van halen
looked right at me saw my face of
desperation of death and just went yeah
he thought you were freaking out on an
acid man i i
literally had to slide out inch by inch
took me 20 minutes to go out and then i
sat in the bleachers by myself i love
access
access is key for a concert
access access is paramount in going to a
concert
access or good seats or a place where
you can be i will not
mush to the front and be smashed into a
bunch of sweaty people anymore you can't
do it
done well
well go i went to i really fell in love
now with the with the rv at a festival
so you can have a place to go back to i
know it's a [ __ ] a bit entitled but
not that much for a few hundred bucks
four people go in six people go in and
then you have a place to shower i gotta
compliment this company on the band
it goes on hard it is a pretty pretty
band oh it's very pretty band insert
yeah sorry about that what does this say
i mean el something to pledge
yeah rolf
corona pledge oh perez carrillo pledge
we're a pledge
very pretty band you can get all your
favorite brands
dude i was talking to some guy we're uh
we're
talking about what a great idea this is
million dollar idea yeah so you know how
they have bark box yes you know yeah
they send you stuff they just have like
nerd stuff they'll send you little
t-shirts from batman shows whatever yeah
yeah backpackers for dogs they send you
a treat a couple treats a couple play
things they know how old your dog is if
it's teething if it's not what is it to
how big is yeah it just comes i got it
for soda
um and i got mabel cigar of the month
they pick out three to five cigars
they already have it that's what we
discovered i got it i'm on it is a good
idea no got me that frosty damn it's
fantastic idea we were like we're gonna
make a billion dollars and then there's
probably 80 different companies who do
it yeah dude i get a bag of five to six
cigars i believe it and they give you
the backgrounds of them and stuff
everything oh that's perfect what it
would pair well with it's actually a one
sheet of all the cigars i got the
t-shirt one for mike for christmas once
and he loved it you know the t-shirt
they did the t-shirt i forgot it was
called that was like being pushed by
everybody for a while
it's two comics
two sick comics two cigars there's an
off camera
yeah this is happening so he's he's he's
on a cigar can't be only two people like
only it's two people it's two comics two
cigars yeah i mean on camera no that's
it yeah i'm with you yes
always i'm a comic over here off camera
we're trying to tell people because
on this show jay
any two comics with the same cigar can
make this podcast and send it to us and
it's going on the youtube page okay if
if it's a if they're if it's good
yeah we're not just putting too [ __ ]
come to us first we're like hey can we
do that and i'll ignore you it's two
comments we know your comments aren't
trouble for doing a two comics two
cigars
no you can't it's a youtube show it's a
youtube show
oh yeah yeah we're on someone else's
show we're guest starring that's right
it's our show but it's two comics and
two cigars um not to jump back a subject
but i want to say ari for always
thinking someone's going to come
negative with her
are you
30
at least 30 things i've done that i
would have never done
that i should do that i never think do
on my own have been brought to me by all
right fear uh
blind
blind uh dinner blind dinner in toronto
i've been to toronto and one in uh crazy
you've done a blender i've done noma the
greatest restaurant in the world for
five years because of ari we got
reservations yep because of that i got
last minute not reservations can you
come down here in an hour's time yeah
and i did the blind restaurant
in toronto and in ho chi minh i believe
you've been to both
you've been to maybe just me i've never
been to one um but yeah that was fun
what else
um i'll say this samari things two
comments two cigars
i'll say this still
today
[ __ ] wake up i'm like i'm hungry
breakfast j starbucks
starbucks absolutely let's go
no ari
with his cool shoes that i now own
well first the fun factoid that mari's
been telling us for a day and a half now
that the highest population of burmese
people
and if you're not familiar with the
burmese people uh you should check out
the second to last rambo
but they're not like that at all
no they're they're much wildier
he wakes up wants to he get he gets out
of boats with guns they're just throwing
trash all over the floors of their
restaurants yes
i will send you this
i'll send you i have a photo i'll send
we'll insert right here listen you woke
up and said burmese food and i went oh
boy he's like what fish eye stew do we
have to eat and i'm like come on you
guys both did it though i was
legitimately pregnant i've been waiting
for one of you to veto like come on not
only did we do it we went to 17 of them
we went to a few closed ones we did not
know that friday between 12 and 3 is a
national burmese holiday it's it's i
think they pray i think it's their
praying time you think they might have
put that in the second last rambo
yeah it would have been a great time to
attack rambo
just gun firing stops
what's going on
actually um
oh
all right shane
well
we found one let me tell you something
i wouldn't if okay i wouldn't go to this
restaurant
ever
yeah
with a soaked red
fire in it i mean the windows were
literally smudged with stuff
smudged
or some kind of weird food just
disgusting and the open sign was like
the open they have it like those jerk
off massage places
in the window where it's just a rainbow
open
and
i mean he you finally we were like you
go check because we literally went to
seven yeah we were all close
first of all you were like no way it's
open it's closed already i'm like we're
180 yards away the best thing is all
right when you opened it and the door
was open the look back you gave of like
now we're in it
he goes
it's like that hitchcock shot where it's
a little tilted and you're like we're
going but he went in and shot the and
went in and left us in the car me and
jay were like we should leave i was
there for over three months time moves
differently in burma
discussing the burmese kid behind the
counter couldn't have been more american
he said it all americanized but he was
like yeah you went to bing bang soup
sure yeah you want the blue you thought
about leaving me you want the pluck
pluck tea you thought about just driving
away oh dude when we looked at that
window
and all the smudge on it
and it was a curtain i could see in
jay's face at least like the dirty
windows you're like he was like ugh
i know come on let's see it through but
why would a restaurant true to form me
and bobby were unaware of the food we
were made nervous by its looks and
contents yeah both overweight
dude
this is the funniest part all the food
comes in jay's like oh i still have
noodles
we went up to the thing this is why
because we're chubbies they had photos
of the food that's what [ __ ] us if
they didn't have photos we would have
got what he got and called it a day but
they had [ __ ] uh yum tum soup they
had uh fung fung foose and
with also burmese uh this is from remark
rohingya which is the people they're
actively trying to wipe out i had a bowl
of
it's just
so delicious it's a morning treat yeah
but mohammed had some stuff i had a bowl
of raw ghoul
ghostbusters too
what's his name
that was just vega wasn't it no yeah but
uh
me and jay ordered
like double meals because we you know
why we do that because if we didn't like
soup that's why we did it because it was
nice you ordered noodles i ordered rice
it was double meals because if we didn't
like this you're ready for some kong
soup oh yeah we had something that we i
know i like fried rice i ordered tea
leaf salad and
mohingo because i was like i want to try
both of these i don't remember these and
try both of them and then you guys are
like oh i guess you're eating two meals
yeah you're right you go you're right
though bobby i'm not going to try even
in the pictures like that soup had like
elbows and [ __ ] coming out of it but
there was stuff in my soup where i had
to ask
you did you i thought what is this and
he's like
it wasn't like crackers you're never
going to love the answer fritter
twitter and you're like okay cool like
you don't know what that means i know
what a freighter is yeah but i do not
know what that was yeah fritter made
with raccoon noses yeah
oh he was like
in myanmar he's like beans i don't know
stir it dude
chop it up so you can't tell there was
so much [ __ ] in that thing that i didn't
know what it was oh and then once you
got into it it was like [ __ ] it yeah
like is this asparagus or frog backs
there was a lot of [ __ ] in that soup and
his salad was [ __ ] nuts it was cold
and warm in the middle there was a pile
of some sort of a nuts
there was peanuts in there but like
smaller peanuts had been left out for
like a long and then fried i tell you
that
peppers that tea was sweet and that
biscuit i got was like biting into a
sand dune
that had popcorn in it in the middle of
the sand yeah so now when you guys get
to heaven and god's like did you try
things on this earth to try i don't know
food from myanmar
oh yeah they'd be like we're right this
way yeah you've you've done that a lot
have i done that with you have you done
stuff because of me
i mean i did stuff with you
no have you done stuff because of me i
brought already corn
yeah he brought me to corn which i would
never go to okay
uh yeah bushcrafting bushcrafting there
you go okay
uh fly fishing oh that was it yeah that
was fun but i also don't have to be
cornered to be convinced fly fishing
like i'm like hell yes that sounds
awesome there's no like i mean i just
never had an invite but i think honestly
like i said you and uh bobby you and are
you getting like me and soda out to the
camp thing oh yeah cabin or not
that was super fun no no no no no comedy
camp one real comedy camp one montreal
quebec canada oh yeah that was another
one
where did we rented a house
that was a real like guys we have five
let's go so we just went to the woods
and yeah wouldn't come because because
her family told her that don't go out to
the woods them white men that was her
fourth excuse that sucks i tell you what
though it's it's weird i was trying to
explain to somebody today again and i've
told my wife this
us three when we get together yeah we
all fall into
our positions
everyone has their natural they go to
where they're yeah you guys went out and
went to get stuff
and i prepared
food
yeah like i you guys my boys went out
yeah and i you're like i'm getting this
grill ready i got everything ready
and you guys came back i'm gonna very
clean it up yeah we had to go for did we
go for a walk no we went for you wanted
to get high groceries oh yeah groceries
and get high
and you came back everything's ready to
go i cooked you he cleaned music you
were in charge of music jay was in
charge of music and then you were in
charge of adventure adventure we went
for a hike
and fire went over we went over the
closed ski slopes that were in the
middle of summer it was so cool
you guys went for a hike i watched a
four-hour documentary on the band
chicago
i'll tell you something interesting oh
yeah peter cetera
two comics two cigars that's what you're
seeing here two comics and it's two
cigars same cigar two of them are two of
them two different kinds different
comics lucas brothers are allowed let's
call those are allowed but generally two
comics two cigars yes we'll allow twins
peter cetera and bill chamberlain both
yeah
names a little crossover is singing in
chicago but both out of the band now
neither of them agreed to be a part of a
four-hour chicago documentary why
they both that's how much i think they
both said
one of them said i forget which one said
if you have nothing nice to say say
nothing
was his response
and uh can you imagine having that much
success
and then just be like [ __ ] them forever
i think that's how a lot of people were
with the comedy store where they're like
thank you for this to start in business
but [ __ ] mitzi
she showed me dead flowers at roseanne
center
she sent her dead roses why i don't know
it's like a [ __ ] message or something
was did they get mad at each other yeah
bitter feuds i guess but then mitzi's
like my god she was on her own all the
time
i like her still it was crazy she loved
her [ __ ] thing but that kind of [ __ ]
where you're like i won't ever set foot
in that place again or i won't ever talk
about chicago again and that's your
number one thing ever in chicago you're
like [ __ ] that or like anyone on chelsea
lately well the other problem is when
they when they do it too you know
they're like i was like what's that fun
like i don't want to talk about it
they're like what happened why did
people hate chase i don't know i don't
know it was the workplace or something
all those people are weird about about
the show about which i see lately yeah
when they do it too late though can also
be a problem like to get back together
like like guns and roses as fun and
nostalgic as it was you're like
it's like it's not too late
he looks ridiculous he was a rebel and a
punk once and then he wasn't a punk
anymore he's just an old rich man who
tried not to be fat anymore well he
doesn't still and you know shows up late
he was always just notoriously bad like
personally but i heard i just watched
the documentary and he's good now sure
he's showing up on time
he's not cancelling shows
he's 55 years old the other thing is
when he sings he's got
like his jeans where his balls are sweat
and that grosses me he also said what it
is now they do with him is his
microphone is turned
way high
so he doesn't have to do much to like
hit anything you know what i mean
he can go lower he's going to be saying
that's the secret to singing well is
almost whispering so you're like
[Music]
and what is that the secret of
to sound good
and then you can hit notes up and down
oh no [ __ ] yeah yeah but if you try to
like did you ever know that i can
already hear it i'm not very good you're
my hero
you're everything i wish i could be
you you're trying to be somebody else
stay you watch i could be that's you
watch the whisper and i can fly higher
there you
go thank you
thank you
thank god for you i don't know
all right
you're so heterosexual
no dude i
admire how much rock solid how much you
know about music like driving up front
with you on this
knowing that you just you're gonna put
on songs i haven't heard in a long time
but i love and i forgot that i love it
big j can feel it too he's like i'll get
you whatever vibe you want if you're
into like hardcore rap i'll get you
somewhere else oh he put us in a nice ma
a nice vibe yeah on the way down yeah
yeah yeah yeah music you you taught me
about your rock
rock
it's fantastic
well the sausage this cigar right now
what do you think of it okay usually in
a cigar with me you light it you're like
this is great i wanted a cigar today too
i [ __ ] was dying for it
and at some point at this point it
usually starts to [ __ ] up the back of my
the sides of my tongue
what do you mean you get tingly and
stuff it's it gets a little like yeah
like a little i can feel it i am not
feeling that with this i burn right a
little burn i am [ __ ] really
it's burning good
i haven't it hasn't gone out on me this
is a really good cigar it's called the
pledge prequel
this is a really i mean this is a you
gotta i mean dude i got a full stomach
that god yeah um from that that four
hours ago burmese yeah but we ate the
restaurant yeah but most of us still
alive in my stomach still yeah i can
feel it
it's like the thing
when you burn somebody's skin
there's a noodle monster in my stomach
and it wants out of my ass or mouth yeah
[ __ ]
it's just too hard boiled it's just two
half hard boiled eggs two more me and
mari's people came out
let's just say if that place if that
whole town was going on letters on
restaurants that would not have gotten
an a
that would knock out an a no for
cleanliness no no they also uh they also
had to give jay the address it goes is
it this place with a bunch of symbols
i mean it was like
writing it was it was in berries there
was we were the only white people in
there oh yeah yeah
and you think all the burmese people not
one of them saw the second last rambo
not one of them not one of them you
might have been laying in weight they
weren't familiar with it
it was really really good food really
good food good cigar i'm really enjoying
this and then we got this show happening
we got 15 minutes until 8 o'clock
15 minutes i do want to say the glc live
at 20 monroe left me all these [ __ ]
cookies yeah
having a lot of fun this and i [ __ ]
nope
yep
there's glc live at 20 minute row so
it's like whatever i got to try this
that's probably for you any of us yeah a
yoga with ari me and bobby could
probably have that one right the glc
live one yeah we could ari shafir
yep this one i love it's the [ __ ]
it's the uh shroom fest logo made by
liam guin that's nice yeah on a [ __ ]
the whole lesson on the cookie yup this
the most interesting yeah
where school is that they made i'm
[ __ ] wearing this shirt right there
you have no kids can't get over that
i mean that could be me and jay
we are dad's skeptic
do you even podcast bro what is that
from
do you know that's from um do you even
podcast me and jay said that once on uh
yeah so it's kind of like yours our
podcast is probably for me and bobby
yeah that one well they made these
microphones for you guys
oh we're probably the microphone ones
yeah with the microphone the microphone
that's more than likely us yeah that's
us can i see that one dude i guarantee
this cookie doesn't taste good but
it's actually a really good microphone
dude bite into that can i give that to
max i'm going to give that to max sure
absolutely
thank you take a bite of the cookie
let's see if the cookies go let's take
best i couldn't you think it's gonna be
good i couldn't not even get my own
cookie i couldn't even get on uh the
podcast there's only three of us here
you guys you guys started a new podcast
and excluded me in the title it's two
comics it's a youtube series it's
youtube series two comics too so guys
if you want to be part of it please send
in and we'll let you know
if they don't smoke a cigar without
freaking out
i'm going to shake my face take a bite
eat your face all you do is your first
skip there you go
i'll leave the glc live at 20 minute row
okay that's pretty neutral that's cool
why don't you eat the one that's for
clearly me and bobby everybody you're
right yeah eat yours
i'll eat my face eat your face
that is nice i'd eat the even podcast
bro one because you're not even sure
what that necessarily what is it though
i feel like it's something i've heard of
do we even podcast it's a great shirt
it is a great shirt dude have i worn
that no i don't have that shirt
this seems like a sales shirt
it is it does seem like that
do you even know it's funny if they put
a sal thing in there
and not one of you
eat the joe rogan experience that's what
i should eat
do you even podcast bro the ultimate
podcast planner
eat the rogan one
what the [ __ ] the shirts
i don't know it's a mystery
one and then in the middle of it go i
feel like it's lacking like social
justice
do you do you think it's going to be
good or bad i think it's going to i say
it's going to be good i think i like
heavy icing i think it's going to be at
best fine
unless that is a real shortbread cookie
now i'm back in i think that's good i
think it's going to be good
softer than i thought it'd be
i feel like jay would like it i feel
like it reminds you of your childhood
yeah
take a bite soft and thick soft and
thick it's in your beard something like
that
it's called two colors she's got some in
your beard though two comments two
cigars two skulls still in your beard
it's in your bed immediately how is it
no
were you right or was i even a real
thing yeah yeah the cookies farm yeah
the ice cream is chalky the icing is it
that's what's that fondant
it's fondant because you're able to
follow an exact [ __ ]
picture it's the price you pay that's
the price you bite
i never eat a cake that looks like a
perfect
sculpture of the cat in the hat it's
gonna taste like [ __ ] these are nice all
those fondant cakes yeah
i will tell them oh this is nice
anyway well i guess we should wrap this
up [ __ ] this place under cookies
this is a very special edition of two
comics two cigars we gotta go on soon
we're gonna go on i guarantee you i
guarantee
that's for different pockets um i
guarantee you
i was thinking let's talk about the
[ __ ] uh scratch-off ticket but that's
that's not something else we gotta get
that's right yes yeah we have to get one
tonight um
i guarantee they're gonna go we're gonna
hold for ten is that okay
i guarantee that too they never don't
hold for ten they always hold for ten
because people are lazy and late and
don't not a park
uh but that's fine especially in a place
where as we the talent had no idea where
to park so i don't know if i could blame
them they said just text the lady
whenever i should tell you where to park
i was all on me no no i'm not arguing
i'm just saying like i'm saying you're
off the tour
but you're back on yeah can i get a
cookie yeah oh what do you want
you want some of this
i want to try it yeah yeah you don't
want a whole cookie that's as close as
you get to being on the joe rogan
experience
oh
the best jokes are the real ones
i'm crying from laughing but also for
other reasons
probably it's in your neck i beg to
differ it's in your neck what do you say
it's a good cookie
look my neck is a beard
dude i'm a [ __ ]
disagree with you
it's a [ __ ] chalky on the on the on the
but i like it still i'm gonna disagree
with dunk that milk
that's solid i'm gonna disagree i think
that that top thing yeah
has a lot of sugar in it the cookie's
sweet but dry
that has a good one that's a one-off
you're not eating two of those
i feel my chest is
my chest hurts right now i don't want
that it's in there i think it's that
[ __ ] burmese
[ __ ] eyeball soup oh i like how they
my eel when my stomach is eating the
cookie
i was so happy last night monkfish got
the cookie
last night everybody the all the fans
were so beautiful at the two shows last
night at that this the comedy club's
name is summit city summit city comedy
club in
in fort wayne indiana unfucking
believable club
great crowd and they were coming up at
the end
you guys were getting these amazing
gifts yeah just these awesome gifts and
as another comic i'm like oh that's
great look good fans but i
did not get a gift i would like a gift
yeah and then at the end we were leaving
getting into the car and a older woman
yeah it was great older woman comes up
robert bobby yes
i'm your daughter
and he goes my son my son is a big fan
and he has a gift
for you and i was like thank you comedy
guys you have to walk with me to come
together
she led you to the back you were that
girl's [ __ ] cup i did it i wanted
that i was like for that gift
when you were walking away this lady's
how old would you say the lady is she's
got to be in her 60s mid to late yeah
yeah and as you're walking away i was
the security guy was there he's like oh
i guess i have to walk with you you know
and so i was walking with him i was like
do you think he's gonna try to [ __ ] her
and he was like i don't know
i bet he is
and i got my gift i was so happy
beautiful box of cigars
long live the kings caldwell that we've
done on this that was their first
original idea episode
you guys can go back and watch um
but yes gave me that and a marble a ykwd
marble which was great give me a
one-headed a one-hitter [ __ ] glasses
shrooms inside i've seen i've seen a lot
of great artwork from [ __ ] degenerate
drug drug addicts
for christine beautiful gift jay got a
pen and a christine from the last year
you all got gifts too i mean he had
gifts for all of us
he did have
i did get again we all got gifts what
beautiful fans
really nice fans yeah they're looking at
them your leakage your [ __ ] ass
and then we spent four and a half hours
at an ihop waiting to get food that
didn't show up right oh my god from uh
it was not the best i've ever been to
but the gluten-free pancakes are the
bigger ones just word of note everywhere
terrible
gluten you know what gluten does it
holds things together it does you're
right and it didn't those pancakes did
not hold together can't spell gluten
without glue
that's true it's not wrong not bad yeah
we had a waitress that was either
14 or 39. i think she was like i think
she was like a 19 year old
it looks like she was hot but grew up
near power lines
and like she may have power like she
might be able to like yeah i'll tell you
what she may be able to see the future
but she cannot bring
uh she cannot bring food in a timely
fashion yeah she could not yeah
oh my god you waited for your [ __ ] are
you waiting for your food you said she
did the thing which is so great and you
were like we all got our stuff and then
you just got
your side of pancake right the main
thing with his breakfast sampler and
you're like what about the breakfast
sample and she goes what i mean like the
breakfast sandwich she goes all right
that's coming and and we both were like
that's 50 50 either
no she just realized oh yeah i saw it in
the back or
[ __ ] i got to put that order and i never
put that in but let me act like to these
people that i did put it in also ask for
over easy eggs open up those yolks
crayons yeah i mean crayons here's the
problem
there's a problem with an ihop anywhere
in the country at
past 12 o'clock also tonight also go
ahead
the
[Music]
12 o'clock
can i just go then no no no no no i'm
going i'm trying to hold on to the
emotions
after 12 o'clock it is
any prison cafeteria
in the country it is sectioned off into
groups of certain people weird yes yeah
come on come here
is it is it no way it lock just push oh
it locked i don't know if you saw their
text they're wondering if you're cool
uh start time ten minutes ten minutes
that's fine all right great that's
awesome we'll i'll be off with this in a
second
all right perfect thanks oh yeah thank
you
you well
10 minutes yes it was that feels nice it
was i mean you had you had gangsters you
had uh the ku klux klan you had you had
[ __ ] uh what's that i'll just join in
right now wasn't i have didn't they have
a scandal for not allowing black people
in
i guess that scandal is over it's over
there was three there was uh there was
three black guys everybody was having a
great time three local rappers eating at
dog balls
they would not give the one table actual
uh plates they made it me with spoons
and dog balls yeah
everybody else and they were also there
was another team but there was like
there was one another group that was a
rock and roll guy an asian nerd uh
like a dorky guy it was like a weird
napoleon dynamite table mm-hmm they were
thinking of joining starting a vigilante
guys i'm talking about there was two and
then there was the guy in the corner on
his computer then there was two lesbians
two older older white women
we were sitting here the ones over there
in the corner over there the chubs i
don't know if they were
they were definitely big yep
and uh
which what dude would [ __ ] one of them
oh you'd be surprised yeah i'd be
surprised it is i'll be honest with you
fort wayne indiana oh you weren't here
me and bobby would have probably just
flirted for the attention
we would have called them on over come
over yeah hey sweetheart what are you
doing what are you doing what do you
want you make those bracelets
gluten-free pancakes
yeah i don't want them either
how about it says here you have to get
bacon or sausage but
maybe have if i told you i'll get both
all right
you're trying to get your dick so you
didn't hear me you didn't get you didn't
get him either i didn't ask for him oh
you didn't no i got the different thing
i got this you got turkey bacon yeah it
bothered me how did you get ham when you
were hamming it up all night
[Music]
that was the name of ari's fake special
i gave him
what was it
i said yeah made it up
that's not like special hamming it up
that's a good ironic one for them
you didn't get ham it bothered you no i
i said uh oh no i got turkey bacon well
no when i said his special what was ice
face
you said from comedy central oh no you
didn't oh no you did yeah i think that
one bombed
because they're also like what i don't
even know what the show is i've never
been to a show before you guys are
already making jokes based on the fact
that they know what the [ __ ] going on
yeah sometimes they're just making each
other laugh i got ham sausage and bacon
you got the breakfast sampler i got the
sample you got the sampler too i got the
pancake sampler oh it doesn't come with
the sample it's just the only thing
different is you don't get all the meats
you just get one of them oh i probably
should we got the meats
barbies
this is so good you know what that is
arby's now has a french dip sandwich and
the commercial says when arby's dip you
dip they dip
that's not bad
it's not bad let's wrap it i'm done so
what do you think of this overall a
[ __ ] great cigar i'd say well i found
it it was like when the guy told me he
was very knowledgeable and i should find
the name of the place guys while you do
this i'm gonna take my pants off so you
can put them out on my dick the way i
love
that's good oh that's good stuff
this is a corporate this is a corporate
show is it though which one
joining a corporate sponsorship we're
getting trying to get corporate
sponsorship don't include me we're gonna
have to beep that part out you could act
like that never happened
this cigar was amazing i loved it
i would buy a box of these it's a
velasquez cigar company i would buy
that's it velasquez cigar company that's
great really helpful
really [ __ ] helpful and he was like
oh you're looking for a good scar get
this man i'm telling you he also had
some uh dos equis or whatever they're
called here's a good rating system would
you buy a box would you buy would you
buy would you buy five or would you buy
one right there were also like
between 11 and 14 bucks they were
perfect that's the normal race if i go
to a cigar bar or not cigar just any
cigar place you know or like when they
have a humidor in the back of a bodega
yes i'm looking in the range if i see it
six dollars ago i'm not getting it so i
don't know what i'm getting i always
look for an our father so i'm like okay
that's probably good my father and then
um and anything else i don't know so i'm
just like 13 and a good looking rapper i
was like yeah you know um
and this was in that range and a great
cigar it's perfect i would buy a box i'd
buy a box this is a box if i had the
room for it yeah buy a box i would buy
some bucks and i would smoke these for
like a month and yeah it'd be like
anyone comes over it's like hey you want
to have a cigar this is the perfect
timing an hour 45 minutes 45 we've been
smoking for 45 minutes an hour 49 and we
started 49 minutes before we started
this yeah and i'm done and i could keep
smoking it i get a toothpick and keep
going with this you know what's going on
bobby's wrists a burn yeah my little
fingertips are burning what's a
toothpick right there you stick a
toothpick in it
and you hold it up so it's off so you're
not holding it so it's imagine my
fingers were a toothpick yeah and then
you could hold it like this and get
right close yeah it's good i i didn't
have to re-light it i didn't have to gas
it out
i mean perfect
it was it got softer which i like yeah
ice is a great one what does ring gauge
mean again the width all the way around
around yeah like you caulk house
centimeters no millimeters
it's a good one it's not centimeters i
believe it's millimeter 60
60 millimeters you're guessing that
right yeah yeah yeah they they don't
know yeah someone's gonna in the
comments it's [ __ ] millimeters
uh please leave a comment
i'll never get that again oh your new
balances your wide sneakers um all right
guys thank you very much for tuning in i
can't get it bobby but they can't even
that's not even on camera i'll be too
bad at that i can't die bobby you're an
itch away help me help me help me give
me motivation bobby yes bobby if you
don't do it i'm worried about you dying
tonight yeah that motivates you i got it
oh thank god
you shouldn't be that red from what
happens
wow this is good
well you worked for it now
other comics hit me and bobby up if uh
we know you you know what i'm talking
about the comments we know yeah two of
you guys on the road
want to smoke a cigar do one of these
but we'll just put them up we're just
gonna have lots of them we're just gonna
have lots of them you can have your
favorite guys two comments talk about it
what it is at the beginning why you want
that one any memories attached to it if
any or just like hey this guy gave me
one who gives yes or and then in the
middle tell us how it is and then the
end
tell us what you thought rate it i would
also say do the hero shots just like
still pictures of the whole thing the
close-up of the [ __ ] whatever do
those beforehand because now i don't i
have to have another one at home
otherwise i won't be able to get those
shots yeah you'll do it i can download
it do whatever way you got to do it yeah
get it and then rate it would you buy a
box would you get five how's it going
you buy a box would you get five would
you get one or would you get none
how many bucks
how many about 10 to 20 depending on
what kind of bucks
uh let me ask you this though i say
three is the magic number which i've
gotten a lot of because it's like this
was good i want to smoke it with a
friend and i also want to have another
what's this ready would you get a box
would you get three yeah um would you
get a box or would you get five
sounds better
could you guys put these out on my penis
now i know you're looking for sponsors
your dick
my dick works as an ashtray
time to go away
wow
[Laughter]
all right i'm done thanks all right